hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
dortmund ich mache heute weiter mit
meiner torten serie denn ich habe heute
wieder richtig leckeres sommerliche
torte für euch heute gibt es eine
heidelberg worte eben zebra look und das
klingt jetzt etwas außergewöhnlich aber
im prinzip ist es ganz einfach ich mache
einen leckeren brösel boden einen
lockeren biscuit drauf und eine leckere
quark sahne creme mit heidelberg und ich
zeige euch jetzt erstmal die zutaten für
den lockeren teig und später in der
zwischenzeit madame impulse boden also
für den teig brauche ich zwei eier 100
gramm zucker etwas vanille extrakt und
eine prise salz jeweils 75 milliliter
mineralwasser und öl ich habe jetzt hier
meist kein öl sonnenblumenöl gibt
genauso
ich habe hier 75 gramm mehl 40 gramm
schweisstec und einen teelöffel
backpulver und das ganze mache ich dann
gleich in meinen back rahmen
den habe ich auch 24 cm eingestellt und
schlaggleichen backpapier 1
zuerst kommen jetzt die eier in die
rührschüssel so wie immer halt bei
meinem urteil
dann kommt der zug die krise sei und
dass vanille extrakt
und dann wird es jetzt erst mal richtig
schaumig gerührt und ich schlag so lang
den teig die backform in backpapier 1
und wenn das ganze dann richtig schön
weiß cremig ist gebe ich noch wasser und
öl mit dazu also ich hab das jetzt als
milliliter abgemessen ihr könnt aber
auch wenn er das öl in cham ab lässt
muss das ungefähr 50 55 gramm nehmen
jetzt ganz kurz unter rühren bei
niedriger stufe
und dann kann ich auch direkt die
trockenen zutaten mit dazu geben so mehl
backpulver und die speisestärke einmal
rein 7 damit keine klümpchen gibt
und das ist auch ganz kurz unterrühren
und den teig fühle ich jetzt in die
vorbereitete backform und durch das
backpapier verhindert ihr einfach dass
der teig jetzt ausläuft
jetzt seht ihr auch dass ich ein relativ
flüssiger teig und deswegen sollte man
da so eine backform immer mit backpapier
einschlagen läuft nämlich nix raus
und so wird der teig dann im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 170 grad ober
und unterhitze für ungefähr 20 bis 25
minuten gebacken und ich nutze jetzt
gleich die zwischenzeit um schon mal den
bröseln boten
jetzt kann ich den brösel teig
zubereiten und ich habe es dafür ein
paar am maritimen hier 100 gramm amara
teenies sie habe ich 100 gramm
mandelblättchen und 125 gramm butter die
welt verlassen
ich hab jetzt heute maritimes weil die
haben halt ein super tolles aroma ihr
könnt natürlich auch löffelbiskuits
nehmen vollkornkekse nehmen oder
irgendwelche andere ihr könnt auch oreo
kekse nehmen also wirklich kekse die er
am liebsten mag ich finde halt hier ist
aroma wirklich super und die werde ich
jetzt gleich zerbröseln allerdings gebe
ich zuerst die butter hier eine top und
verlasse die und die mandeln gebe es in
der pfanne und die reste nämlich beides
parallel und sind gleichzeitig im großen
tag
jetzt habe ich die keks brösel in einer
großen schüssel drin lebt da direkt die
butter mit rein
das ist auch echt so als entweder können
dann merkt drunter machen die sich dann
auch richtig schön ich finde unter
torten wenn da so ein knuspriger teig
mit grundstück finde ich immer ziemlich
lecker entweder möglich oder als und
brüssel tagt großen teil geht schneller
und ich finde da kann man halt auch
super toll aroma mit reinbringen durch
die verschiedenen kekse die mandeln
können wir jetzt auch gehackte mandeln
nehme ich habe deutsch die gehobelte
mandeln stamm eine chronische nehmen
oder kann man auch unternehmen genau
dann einfach alles miteinander
vermischen
ziemlich heiß deswegen bitte nicht mit
den händen
sagst du mal rein rief
wo alles richtig auf den weihnachtsmarkt
naja eigentlich ein sommertheater
natürlich diamanti nie wahrscheinlich
eher im winter kamer spekulatius kate
ist eine ruhige zeit so jetzt habe ich
hier noch einen zweiten tortenring wenn
jetzt keine 2 habt müsste halt kurz auf
den teig warten und dann den rahmen
lösen und dann eben diesem rahmen
benutzen
den habe ich jetzt auch in backpapier
eingeschlagen damit es nicht an meiner
tortenplatte klebt immer gar keinen top
bringen
nicht mal eine springform uhr kam es auf
dem blech man braucht schon eine
umrandung dass es eben eine schöne runde
torte wird oder man nimmt halt das
doppelte rezepte können sie auf dem
blech machen aber auch mit torten rahmen
also wer schon gut
jetzt drücke ich hier den teig schön
flach
das geht am besten mit zum teil schärfer
und dann nehme ich noch so ein glas zur
hilfe
und dann könnt ihr euch entweder ein
glas nehmen oder so ein stampfer ich
habe zum kartoffelstampf 2 übrigens von
mir neulich habe ich nur ein glas hier
um gemacht und dann sagt sie irgendwann
im doch das hier des kartoffel stunde
geht immer so cool ich habe letzte woche
auch die hoch selbst hatte für meinen
bruder gemacht und die war fünfstück ich
und ich habe alle fünf stockwerke mit
hand mit dem pinsel gemalt und beim
fünften stockwerk also der wollte zu
einer mensch darauf wie auf seine
einladungskarte und beim fünften
stockwerk bisher mir mama wie
sonnenschein ich einfach die
einladungskarte längst drauf und macht
wie so eine schablone ist bei der
standorte soll sie von mir mit
einladungskarte noch neun effekt
geschmissen
es ist ein ernst dass das mein bruder
nagetier wurde aller einzelnen laser
nämlich eingraviert ja und ich
kombiniere klein der brüssel boden es
jetzt schön flach und weil du ebenso
frech war statist es gleich in der
kühlschrank stellen und ich war dann
ganz kurz bis der brösel boden schön
kalt ist bis der bizkit dann abgekühlt
ist und dann setzen wird die torte
gleich zusammen und können sie dann
gleich fertig machen also mit der creme
und so weiter bis gleich
der boden ist es schön abgetötet der
teig ist auch abgekühlt und sie zeige
ich euch noch die zutaten für die
füllung und zwar sind es jetzt zwei
schichten einmal einer heidelberg
schicht ich habe jetzt hier 400 am
heidelberg und eine tüte magazine das
ist ein pflanzliches geliermittel also
statt gelatine benutze ich das dann habe
ich hier 705 750 gramm magerquark 150
gramm oder zucker eine halbe zitrone
dafür brauche ich den saft etwas vanille
extrakt hier habe ich 600 gramm und
schlagsahne drin
fuchs verständlich ausgekippt und ich
nehme dafür etwas dran abfahrt sagt ihr
euch gleich und für die deko brauchen
wir gleichen rothaupt blaubär aus
heidelbeeren die berglauf er nach
sperren alles das gleiche zuerst nehmt
ihr jetzt die heidelbeeren die wir für
die füllung benutzen da gebe ich nämlich
jetzt in einem topf wir müssen uns
beeilen cell ich muss zur arbeit
ich bin ich mir rat der steinbruch ruft
der bagger schweiz schon nach mir genau
und die muss ich jetzt einmal pürieren
morath ist macht schnell ich kann
dann gebe ich da das ak tina pulver mit
rein ihr könnt jetzt natürlich auch
statine benutzen
aber ich bin uns halt lieber gerne die
pflanzliche variante ich nie magazine
und deutsch sitz links dicht es kommt
jetzt auf den herd und muss da zwei
minuten gekocht werden ansonsten kann es
nicht richtig wirken und dann wirds halt
fest
die halten dürfen jetzt zwei minuten
aufkochen und ich fühle es jetzt einmal
um einmal damit dass eben schneller
abkühlt und außerdem soll ihr die tolle
phase mal sehen
guck mal wie schön dunkel das ist
richtig gut aus
das was jetzt hier kurz an der seite
stehen und kümmere mich schon mal um die
creme und zwar lasse ich die schlagsahne
hier in der küche schlagen bevor ich das
aber mache kümmere ich mich um den quark
wobei ich mache es einfach als parallel
gebe ich jetzt noch diese sonderfahrt
mit rein
das ist aber erst mal bissel aufhören
und es hat nämlich halt ganz gern weil
es auch rein pflanzlich gut für
vegetarier geeignet und die sahne wird
einfach auch direkt fest also ich muss
später dann nicht warten bis sie noch
mal fest sondern geht direkt fest so
kurz aufschlagen
und dann kommen da so sechs teelöffel
mit rein
man müsse halt aufpassen vor allem wenn
ihr mit einer küchenmaschine arbeitet
weil die sahne da sehr schnell fest wird
die sahne habe ich jetzt kurz kühl
gestellt und kann mich jetzt nicht klar
wir müssen uns für mich ein mit
mineralischen abgezogen ich möchte krieg
spielte einfach kein trottel zum essen
weil sie muss auch kühl stellen
meine arbeitskollegen warten schon
kriege morgen dann kommt hier vanille
extrakt mit rein
hat die spülmaschine heute macht mich
ganz verrückt dann die zitrone also dem
saft von gehalten zitrone hasse euch
gesagt dass mit der sony hat habe ich
schon als zählt das müsste dann immer in
die spülmaschine mit reinen schweizer
als spülmaschinen dem dann kommt auch
noch der puderzucker mit rein und ich
lege mir auch mit zwischen die achsel
manchmal haben rat johann strauß okay
das wäre ich jetzt hier kurz erstmal bei
niedriger stufe damit ab oder zu greifen
hat rausspringt beim hochschalten
und auch hier gebe ich jetzt dann ab hat
mit rein damit es auch gleich schön
festwirt und erreichen so etwa vier
teelöffel
sieht man auch direkt wie festes dann
wird also dieser quark und honig kurz
die sahne aus dem kühlschrank und kann
die noch unterheben
einfach jetzt vorsichtig unterheben im
teig sauber
jetzt lese ich hier von brösel boden
kurz den torten rand ich kann das
backpapier abziehen das kind nicht mehr
mit auf meiner tortenplatte das
funktioniert auch relativ gut weil es
sehr schön fest ist nur aufpassen dass
ich nicht
dann streicht ich da ein bisschen von
der creme drauf also nicht so viel hat
seinen kleinen klecks damit er biscuit
boden als gleich darauf kleben kann
den habe ich jetzt schon hier auf
twitter darauf gestürzt und sie das
backpapier noch ab
ich kann es dann einfach mit sommer
andere teig hätte da drauf geben
ich habe hier unten dem krümeligen
knusprigen boden dann den lockeren boden
jetzt gebe ich den teig rahmen wieder
außen rum zu diesen taten bringen
und jetzt gebe ich immer abwechselnd
einen esslöffel von der creme in die
mitte dann einen esslöffel von dieser
heidelberg creme die ich jetzt noch
nicht ganz abgekühlt also ein bisschen
warm ist noch viel mehr hätte abkühlen
lassen können aber das ist jetzt nicht
schlimm
früher einfach noch ein bisserl
das machen wir immer abwechseln
man lasse mir einen daumen müssen bei
dir zwei zähler
wir bauen zwei zähler ein der eine 10
immer wenn du das wort einfach satt
unter anderem zählt die kalorien und ich
glaube der kanzlerin selber jetzt grade
mal durchdrehen wird rauchen mit der
kalorienzähler ist dann immer vorne
ordert es einfach weil sie nicht einfach
ja schon weit vorne
apokalypse damit bei dieser tat mit
sicherheit durch drehen ein bisschen
creme habe ich jetzt hier aufgehoben
also vielleicht so ein viertel oder ein
fünftel von der gesamten creme und die
torte die habe ich immer mal
zwischendurch auch so wissel geschüttelt
damit flach wird weil wenigstens
streicht dann schon die optik wieder weg
und das klappt auch relativ gut und
jetzt gebe ich das erstmal in den
kühlschrank die creme auch und
verstreicht und später die weiße creme
noch mal ganz oben drauf nämlich einen
weißen abschluss und hier habe ich mir
auch noch ein bisschen von der heide der
soße aufgehoben
die gebe ich mir auch noch für die deko
auf und wenn das jetzt abgekühlt ist
sollen etwa einer stunde braucht sie
schon 12 stunden dann machen wir das
noch drauf und dann zeige ich euch wie
die tor das hätte ich die kuh die torte
ist jetzt schon abgekühlt und jetzt kann
ich den torten rand einmal lösen mache
ich mit hilfe von seiner palette
trotten meint rocken bringen messer ist
greifen der spülmaschine
und ich hab diesen rest was ich noch
übrig hatte also von dieser heidelbeer
masse habe ich einfach nur mal kurz
erwärmt weil es hat ja schon angefangen
zu studieren bzw war schon fest und
damit ich es eben gleich für die deko
verwenden kann musste jetzt einfach mal
ein bisschen wahr mache es gebe ich die
weiße creme da und verstreicht mit einer
winkel palette
dann sieht man von aussen diese optik
hat gleich nicht mehr aber man hat dann
halt gleich im anschluss
also die oberfläche der torte habe jetzt
weiß gelassen beim brand habe ich jetzt
geguckt dass sich das weiße bisschen
vermischt mit dem lila jetzt nämlich
noch ein löffel und mache so ein paar
kleine vertiefungen rein muss jetzt auch
noch regelmäßig sein denn da gebe ich
von diesem jerry noch mit rein also was
ich da vorn gemacht habe
immer so einem tupfer und den dann
geradezu bisserl so einziehen
jetzt nämlich die restlichen heidelberg
und gibt sie noch als deko mit obendrauf
also ihr könnt sie gerne auch anders
statt dekorieren minister anders haben
wollte aber ich denke so ist eine ganz
einfache deko die jeder hin bekommt so
ein bisschen im löffel ohne spritzbeutel
können auch kinder mitmachen oder der
ehemann murat ist schon weg der jetzt
leider nicht manager der musste schon
zur arbeit
meine torte weiß leider noch ein
bisschen zu weich als ich hab sie leise
so ein bisschen flach und tief gedrückt
also am besten lassen sie wirklich so
drei bis vier stunden im kühlschrank
bevor ihr sie dekoriert oder bevor er
sie eben anschneidet aber ich habe zu
wenig zeit deswegen wird jetzt sofort
angeschnitten ich will jetzt einfach mal
hier komplette ring mit bedenken da
schaut der brösel boden da auch schön
durchschneiden
ich wollt
dann hat auch das stück mit
runtergeschmissen naja ich probiere
trotzdem für euch also da unten schön
die sagt rüdiger bösel boden dann der
lockere bizkit und dann die creme und im
sturm mit der kamera herunter schwenke
und man kann existierender mund stecken
und geschmack ist fast die torte
wirklich es ist fast echt gut zusammen
alles die heilig bayern mit dieser gibt
es einen ganz eigenen geschmack also
sind so wie himbeeren oder erdbeeren und
heidelbeeren haben echt so ein richtig
eigene geschmack richtig lecker und
passt wirklich gut zu diesen amanatidis
zu den mandeln daher lockere bizkit
boden also ich finde die müsste auf
jeden fall mal nachmachen
ich werde bestimmt noch mal nach backen
und dieses mal wissen länger im
kühlschrank lassen dann schau
datenschnipsel schöne uns bisserl
einfacher und wenn ihr das rezept nach
machen wollt dann geht einfach auf
meinem blog auf sallys - blog.de
da geht es noch mal die genaue anleitung
und die zutaten und ich wünsche euch
ganz viel spaß beim nachbacken ich
genieße jetzt noch ein stück kuchen und
habe zwei abend ist ahnt es